after six years of marriage kim
kardashian and kanye west
are calling it quits at the end of the
day life is about being happy
a source tells et that kim filed for
divorce on friday
and is asking for joint legal and
physical custody of their four children
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago
and one-year-old psalm the source adds
that kanye is fine with the joint
custody agreement and the two
are committed to co-parenting together i
think our kids will see
you know kanye and i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them
and just to find their own path the
source notes that the two have a prenup
and neither kim nor kanye are planning
to contest it
also the source adds that they are
already in the process of reaching a
property settlement agreement
a second source tells et that there is
no drama between the 43 year old rapper
and the 40 year old kkw beauty founder
quote they are amicable and fully
aligned when it comes to the kids
he might say things that might get
misinterpreted and people don't see the
context behind it but i always know his
heart
the source added that the two had been
going to marriage counseling but they
didn't make much headway
divorce is something that has been
discussed off and on for the past
year but kim has been reluctant to move
forward with that
and another source recently told et that
while their romantic relationship has
run its course
they will always be in each other's
corner kim and kanye will forever love
one another and will root for each other
a source tells et that while it's been
an overwhelming process for kim
it's something she knew had to happen
adding that kim saw
her parents successfully co-parent same
with her sister courtney and scott
disick
so she knows her situation will be no
different
you